sehr verehrten Zuschauer und
Zuschauerinnen begrüßen sie gemeinsam
mit mir die soeben aus Mailand gelandete
Mode Ikone des Jahres 1943 Lösung von 19
ist mein Leben
und mein Leben ist mir heilig und was
mir auch heilig ist ist Germanys next
Topmodel von daher schon wir uns heute
gemeinsam die Models der Staffel
fangen wir doch einfach mal direkt an
mit der Maria
das ist Maria
maria ist Buchbinderin und hat schon als
kleines Kind von einer Karriere als
Model geträumt du hast davon geträumt
aber Lucius von lützenburg
war schon längst Model als er noch im
kackbauch war machen wir weiter mit der
lieben Larissa hier vorne das ist sie
Larissa stabile Karre Digger machen wir
weiter mit der lieben Liliana hier vorne
das ist Liliana tomam habt ihr alle
gleiche Karre oder was diana ist 21
Jahre alt kommt aus Rheda-Wiedenbrück
und Liliana beschreibt sich als
authentisch einzigartig und
pflichtbewusst ich würde mich einfach
nur als Topmodel beschreiben
jasmin ist die nächste Kandidatin meine
lieben Freunde das ist Jasmin
die hat sich ein Beispiel genommen an
Sandra mit dem leopardenoberteil
sie ist 21 und studiert in Wien denn die
gebürtige passauerin studiert in Wien ja
das liegt dann auch nahe anna ist die
nächste Kandidatin die wir uns hier
heute anschauen das ist nämlich sie
ist 20 Jahre alt und Studentin aus
Neu-Ulm nennen sie studiert BWL und
beschreibt sich als kleiner Sonnenschein
also ich bin ein großer Sonnenschein das
hier ist Alisha sie ist die sechste
Kandidatin die wir uns heute anschauen
sie ist 19 Jahre alt Abiturientin aus
Berlin sie macht in ihrer frühen Jugend
sportario
kommen wir als nächstes hier zu
Alexandra und zu Alexandra steht hier
dass die 21 Jahre alt ist und aus Köln
kommt
momentan
linda ist die nächste Teilnehmerin hier
sie hat ein gelbes Hemd haben sie damit
ein bisschen aus wie ein Schiedsrichter
allerdings ist die 20 Jahre alt und
auszubietende Auszubildende aus
niederelf Hilfe machen wir weiter mit
Marie-Sophie die einen sehr gewagten
Style hier an den Tag legt man weiß
allerdings natürlich immer nie ist das
deren wirklicher Style oder GNTM gesagt
komm wir wollen dass du so auftrittst
wer weiß wer weiß Marie-Sophie ist auf
jeden Fall 19 Jahre alt kommt aus
Konstanz
in ein Minecraft ein ehemaliger
Minecraft Youtuber sich einen Dance
überlegt hat
Konstanz
weil das ist
machen wir weiter mit der nächsten
Kandidatin namens Luca
ja luca ist 19 Jahre alt Abiturientin
aus Bitterfeld Wolf finde luca hat die
Abitur absolviert und hat hobbymäßig
schon gemodelt so wie ich
nur das bei mir halt nicht hobbymäßig
war sondern ich einfach daran auch
Millionen verdient habe ne das ist
Sascha meine lieben Freunde und dascha
ist 20 Jahre alt kommt aus Solingen und
wurde in der Ukraine geboren sagt die
Ukraine oder Ukraine
2005 kamen sie mit ihren Eltern nach
Deutschland die 20-Jährige Spielzeit
zwölf Jahren Gitarre außer dem Tanz
zeichnet und singt sie sehr gerne es ist
schön
was ich nur gerne mache ist model
ich bin Model lena ist die nächste
Kandidatin fährt hier mit ihrem Fahrrad
rum sie ist 21 Jahre alt und studiert in
meinen Spessart
Lena als Studentin und wohne auf dem
Land sie hat immer ein Lächeln auf den
Lippen und lebt nach dem Motto sei die
Veränderung die du dir in der Welt
wünscht ich verwette 10.000 €, dass sie
das auch in ihrer instabio stehen hat
Amina ist die nächste Teilnehmerin sie
ist 21 Jahre alt und studiert in Berlin
im sechsten Semester Soziologie oh mein
Gott sind ja wirklich Leute dabei Alter
die haben nicht mehr erreicht als ich
denn ich bin Model das hier ist Mira und
Mira ist eine 19-jährige Studentin aus
Bordesholm Digger was ist in Deutschland
alles für Städte gibt ne
Wahnsinn Mira ist der zielstrebig und
lässt sich durch nichts aus der Ruhe
bringen weil wenn die mich sehen würde
Ruhe für dich das geringste Problem
ich habe schon in meiner Kindheit
alles aus der Ruhe gebracht
immer ordentlich für Aufsehen gesorgt
dann fühle ich mich auch wohl
außer einmal
das hat mir
hatte ich Durchfall und dann haben mich
paar anderen in Basketballkorb dann
Mareike auch vor der fetten karyem rum
putzen hier sie ist 25 Jahre alt damit
gehört sie wahrscheinlich zu der
ältesten bis vor kurzem war Basketball
ihre große Leidenschaft ich habe auch
zwei große das ist Ashley meine lieben
Freunde die posieren irgendwie alle an
den gleichen Orten es ist ein bisschen
Corona die hätten jetzt natürlich nicht
irgendwie nach Thailand Australien und
Amerika fliegen können Jura und du oh
Gott die kann Jura da muss ich mich ganz
schnell verpissen die kann mich
wahrscheinlich mit jeder Aussage die ich
betätige hops nehmen nana ist die
nächste Teilnehmerin sie ist 19 Jahre
alt und Abiturientin aus Hamburg
Stopp gewonnen geworden müssen wir gar
nicht mehr lesen Romina ist 21 Jahre alt
und kommt aus Köln
ich wohne nicht werden Köln habe da aber
sechs Jahre gewohnt also Romina hat gute
Wahl Romina ist selbstständig und
begeistert über 85.000 Abonnenten auf
ihrem Instagram auch Gott komm Weg
Vanessa hier meine lieben Freunde sie
sieht aus wie eine Schauspielerin finde
ich
eins zu eins na gut vanessa ist 21 Jahre
alt Studentin und ist ein Mädchen
Ricarda ist die nächste praktische
Praktikantin bin ich los Ricarda ist die
nächste Teilnehmerin und sie ist 21
Jahre und Studentin aus
Pinneberg
ach bei Hamburg klar hat eine
Leidenschaft fürs Schreiben in ihrer
Freizeit verfasst sie aus ihrer eigenen
Kurzgeschichte ein Buch das möchte sie
unbedingt veröffentlichen die
Studentinnen kann man
Wirtschaftspsychologie meditiert zwei
bis dreimal
es gibt halt solche und solche
Praktikanten
Teilnehmer
es gibt hier die
wirtschaftspsychologiestudenten die
nebenbei ein eigenes Buch rausbringen
und meditieren
und dann gibt es die mit 85.000 Leuten
auf Instagram das hier ist die Solin ich
hoffe mal ich spreche das richtig aus
sie ist 20 Jahre alt und Abiturientin
aus Hamburg
auch gewonnen brauchen wir gar nicht
weiter chanel ist die nächste Person
ist eine 20-jährige Auszubildende aus ja
und Chanel macht eine Ausbildung zur
Erzieherin ich muss auch mal dringend
muss ich erzogen werden das hier ist
Romy sie nimmt auch Teil an der
diesjährigen Staffel GNTM das ist
logisch weil sonst wäre sie nicht in
diesem Video mit drin kommen wir nun
allerdings auch schon zur letzten
Kandidatin die bei der diesjährigen
Staffel GNTM 2021 mit dabei ist und zwar
ist es Sarah
ohne h diesmal der Pulli ist sieht nach
merge aus dem luca-shop.de
allerdings sollte es nicht um
merchandise gehen sondern um Sarah denn
sie 20 Jahre alt und Studentin aus
Aichtal bei Stuttgart die Studenten hat
bereits ein Modelerfahrung gesammelt
ihre guten Chance mit GNTM sieht sie in
ihrem R1 ein in ihrem einzigartigen und
außergewöhnlichen Look Musik ist die
große Leidenschaft der 20-Jährigen am
liebsten entdeckt die neue Songs oder
geht auf Konzerte oh das ist jetzt
natürlich blöd mit Corona
naja was allerdings gut ist ist
an Corona
ihr könnt zu Hause bleiben meine Videos
gucken
von der abonniert mal
jetzt unter dem Video
soll ich auch noch auf die folgenden dem
also auf meinem Kanal ne
gut lass mal
[Musik]